welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation
titled introduction to film fret for
screening applications
it's my pleasure to introduce you today
dr
david andrews dr andrews is the director
of and senior scientist
in biological sciences at sunnybrook
research institute and the professor of
biochemistry and medical
biophysics at university of toronto
and a tier one canada research chair in
membrane biogenesis for a complete
biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them through the q and a box
our speaker will address those questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming dr
andrews i will now turn the presentation
over to him welcome sir
well thank you for the introduction and
thank you for everyone who's come
to listen to the presentation a
more descriptive version of my title is
really
measuring protein-protein interactions
in live cells
using fluorescence lifetime imaging
microscopy and forster resonance energy
transfer
and that's a real mouthful which is why
of course i use the shorter title
but in the cell there are two really
main things that proteins do enzymatic
reactions
and interactions and most of the drugs
that are available today
target the enzymatic actions
of the different proteins in the cell
but there's been recent success
in targeting protein protein
interactions particularly with a
molecule i'm very familiar with which is
called venetoclax
which has turned out to be a block best
buster drug
for chronic lymphocytic leukemia and is
now being introduced into other
leukemia type diseases and the
pathway that it interacts with is what's
shown here and you can see from this
pathway that there are many many
different proteins
some of which are enzymes but many of
these
are regulated by protein-protein
interactions
meaning that there are a plethora of
targets
potential pharmaceutically relevant
targets
within the cell for which we have very
little
in the way of drugs that have been
designed because
pharma in general considers these to be
very hard targets
however they are starting to fall and so
what's now needed is ways to actually
measure protein-protein interactions
inside live cells and so the
interactions i'm going to talk to you
about
today are shown here just a small
section of that total graph describing
programmed cell death mechanisms in
cells
and the particular proteins i'm
interested in
are the bcl2 family of proteins which
regulate the commitment step in
programmed cell death the particular
program
cell death called apoptosis this this
takes place at the outer mitochondrial
membrane because the goal
of a pro-apoptotic protein is to
permeabilize that membrane
and the reason i'm using these for this
particular talk today
is because this is probably one of the
most difficult
examples of being able to measure
protein protein interactions
in live cells because these proteins are
targeted to the same subcellular
compartment
and to the membrane of that compartment
so collisions are a big
influence on what would appear to be
interactions
and many of the technologies that are
used
to look at proximity proximity based
ligation
assays or bimolecular fluorescence
complementation
assays so-called if c
protein complementation with luciferase
all of those kinds of things
are really proximity assays as opposed
to actual binding assays
and the advantage of phlegm fret
as you will see today is that it
provides a way to actually
measure binding interactions
quantitatively in live cells
and now with recent developments at high
enough speed that we can actually use
this
in early stage drug development
so i'm going to go through the
underlying principles
of flim fret explain why this is in my
view
an ideal way of measuring protein
protein interactions in live cells
talk to you about the advantages but
also some of the disadvantages of the
technique
and one thing to keep in mind right from
the beginning
a major disadvantage is false negatives
whereas many of the other techniques the
problem is false positives
so in another sense flim fret is
a wonderful complementary tool to the
proximity type based assays
because they have opposite detractions
and therefore
if you get a positive with both you're
absolutely sure you're measuring a real
protein-protein interaction in the cell
you're not going to need to know a lot
about these proteins or memorize all the
names
we're going to use them relatively
interchangeably
the important point here is that these
are membrane proteins
whose function is through
protein-protein interactions
okay so we want to screen for protein
protein interactions
in in this particular forum
and that means that we need to be able
to automate this and we need to be able
to make it
fast so this
is the underlying technique at the
moment it requires
fusion of the target and bait proteins
to fluorescence proteins
generally these kinds of techniques are
used all the time in cuvettes with
purified proteins
in that case you're using very low
molecular weight dyes and so
there's very it's very infrequent that
you have
problems due to the labeling here you
have to be much more care
careful about the labeling because the
fluorescence proteins can be
as large or larger than your bait and
prey in this particular case they're
roughly the same size
so here i'm illustrating the interaction
of bclxl an antihepatic protein that
prevents cell death
with one of the bh3 proteins and there's
a bunch of different bh3 proteins that
all bind to bcl excel
and the net result of that is that both
proteins are anchored to the membrane
and both proteins are inactivated by
this interaction
so we refer to this as mutual
sequestration
and so it's very important to be able to
measure
the amount of monomers and
complexes and where they are in the cell
to be able to understand how a cell is
going to respond for example to
chemotherapy
and also how it's going to respond to
drugs designed
to separate those two protein-protein
interactions
okay so what is fret fret as
fluorescence resonance energy transfer
and it's based on illuminating a
fluorophore
and when you eliminate that fluorophore
two things happen
one that we're all familiar with is that
a
light that's absorbed by the fluorophore
will be re-emitted
at a longer wavelength due to a loss of
energy
to in the fluorescent state and that's
the basis of all our fluorescence
microscopes
the other thing that we don't often
think about is that there's a time delay
between
the excitation with the blue light and
the emission here of the green light
and that time delay there's some
structural rearrangements in the
fluorophore
and some vibrational things and that's
where some of the energy is lost
and why the wavelength is longer but
that delay time is the fluorescence
lifetime and that's what we're going to
use
to measure energy transfer in a
microscope as opposed to a cuvette
so here we have the emission
wavelengths from this fluorophore
when it's excited by the blue light i've
got a green emission
and what's required for energy transfer
is that you have another fluorophore
and this fluorophore has to be very very
close
the furthest you can detect any kind of
energy transfer event
is 100 angstroms but really at 50 it's
gotten very weak
and that's because the energy transfer
probability goes down with the 10 to the
-6
so you're taking distance and dividing
it by 10 to the minus 6
to get the amount of energy that's
transferred
so this this becomes a really good
molecular ruler
for distances between 10 and 50
angstroms
i.e real binding now that
other fluorophore has to have a
excitation spectrum that overlaps
the emission spectrum of the donor
for you to get energy transfer and when
you do get energy transfer one of the
things that you then see
is a decrease in the emission of the
donor
and an increase in the fluorescence from
the acceptor because some of that energy
is transferred
often people think that the green light
is exciting the red fluorophore
that's not the case fluorescence
resonance energy transfer is
non-radiative transfer of energy which
is why they really have to be so close
together
and there are multiple things that can
affect the fluorescence emissions
of both molecules in a cuvette you're
good to go if you measure the loss of
emission from the donor
it's much more difficult to measure
quantitatively the
stimulated emission of the acceptor
and in a microscope this is really
problematic because
the underlying assumption for
calculating energy transfer
is that you know the relative
concentration of the donor
and the acceptor not in the population
of cells
not in the cell not in the mitochondria
or
some membrane of the cell but in every
pixel of the image you have to know
the relative concentration of donor and
acceptor
so if you're using a sensor where the
two are
genetically linked you're okay otherwise
it's really impossible to use
quantitatively
despite what the microscope companies
will tell you about their microscopes
okay so how does this then work and how
do we use
lifetime to get a measurement
of fluorescence resonance energy
transfer or fret
so what happens when the fluorophore
goes into an excited state
here it's residence lifetime is 2.8
nanoseconds
and then you get a decay curve
and that's because they don't all decay
at exactly
2.8 nanoseconds they decay with all
kinds of different
lifetimes it's a stochastic process
remember i said they wobble around they
lose a little bit of energy
and and then they emit a photon so you
really need to
collect this curve which is different
times after excitation that photon is
emitted
so that you can measure the lifetime and
by convention
that's the fluorescence divided by e so
not quite a half
and that time that it takes for
fluorescence divided by e
is then tau zero or the fluorescence
lifetime
of the donor by itself
when you have a donor and an acceptor
and they're actually close enough to
each other to get energy transfer
that tau decreases and the reason it
decreases
is that the energy transfer event
is more probable the longer time goes on
that the two
fluorophores are in close proximity so
that means you preferentially
lose the ones that would take a long
time to decay
and so the decay curve changes shape and
looks like this
so when you have a fret tau fret here
now you see that the a naught divided by
e
is much smaller in terms of time
after excitation because you
preferentially lost
the ones with a longer lifetime so if we
can measure
tau zero our tau zero and tau
fluorescence
or top fret then we can
be able to get an estimate of the number
of molecules that are bound to each
other
giving us the shorter lifetime now this
is
in theory right in practice when you
try and do this the instruments are not
perfect
and so there's also an instrument
response time that's involved
so what you're doing is you're pulsing a
laser and that's shown by those
two little blue triangles with the
pulsed laser
so you send out a pulse of the laser and
when you do that you start a stopwatch
and then that pulse goes through the
scanning confocal
it hits the specimen and then after a
period of time
usually a few nanoseconds the photons
get returned
and what you're doing then is taking
those photons that come back
to a time correlated single photon
counting device
and essentially what you're doing is
measuring the time it took from when you
started the stopwatch
till the arrival of the first photon and
then you stop
your stopwatch and you have to do that a
whole bunch of times to be able to build
up
this decay curve that you see in red and
the reason it doesn't look like those
theoretical ones is because the
instrument response time
has to be deconvoluted from this so you
have that lag at the beginning because
the
machines are just not fast enough
remember that this is happening in a
very short time right
about two to four nanoseconds
and you to get a good representation of
that curve
you need about a thousand photons back
and you don't want to get a photon every
time you flash the laser or you'd get
two sometimes
so that means you have to flash more
than a thousand times
which means that we end up flashing the
laser forty thousand to eighty thousand
times a second
and starting and stopping the stopwatch
forty to eighty thousand times a second
to be able to
record this data so when the sales
person tells you it's going to cost you
a fair bit now you know why
because this is a pretty difficult thing
to measure
and to do this in screening mode
you'll see is even more complicated
nevertheless the principle is actually
really simple
you have your venous bcl excel here and
your bh3 protein whichever one that is
the venous alone is 2.8 nanoseconds
there's no fret
when you've got fluorophore emitting at
2.3 nanoseconds then
the bh3 protein is bound to bcl excel
so that's that's the whole principle
behind the thing
then in practice how are you going to
use that information
what i'm illustrating here is one image
area so this is essentially one pixel
so that blue is the laser that's
exciting one spot on the mitochondrial
membrane
and within that spot you'll see that
there's three bcl excels all with a
venous
there's no binding partner in this
pixel of the image so the lifetime of
the venus is 2.8 nanoseconds
if we now introduce the binding partner
typically by transient transfection then
this decay curve that we see here
centered around 2.8 nanoseconds is going
to shift
and it shifts when you have a single
m cherry bh3 protein in this particular
case
now in this pixel you have one at 2.3
2 at 2.8 so the lifetime
is actually around 2.7 right because
you've got 2.8 plus 2.8 plus 2.3
divided by 3. and so what you need to do
then is to get lots of different pixels
that have increasing amounts of m cherry
in them
now you see that the lifetime drops to
2.43 nanoseconds
and when we finally saturate you have to
have a lot of excess to be able to
saturate
then you finally get down to 2.3
nanoseconds
so that means that by using a transient
transfection and lots of different cells
or areas of cells with
different amounts of your acceptor
you get the information that you need to
get a binding curve
so what does this look like here's some
representative data
this is when we were first getting going
in this kind of thing and
you'll see here cells we typically have
the donor stably expressed
so this is a cell line these are mcf7
cells
expressing venous pcl excel and then
below that where you have m cherry bad
that's a transient transfection
into those cells of the m cherry bad and
the computer automatically
finds regions of interest within those
cells
as is typical in screening applications
you automatically reject cells
that have hit the edge of the detection
area so the three cells at the bottom
are excluded
and we are left with three cells that we
can analyze
cells one and two there's a high
expression of the m cherry bad
and cell 3 there's very little if any
m cherry bat so when you then measure
the intensity weighted fret flim or flim
fret
the red there is the m cherry
and that is because of the change in
lifetime
right so the lifetime is illustrated on
the graph below
which goes from red to white to blue so
in a cell that's not expressing
any bh3 protein that's cell number three
you have that photon histogram that's
blue and colored blue in the intensity
weighted image
so that's where you have no fret
then in the other peak underneath the
red
cells that's the two red cells where you
are expressing the m cherry bad and it's
binding to bcl excel
and the lifetime has changed the area
under the curve
of each of those two peaks is just the
number of pixels
so that's actually not relevant to
measuring the phlegm fret what's
relevant there is the distance between
those two peaks
because that distance between the two
peaks is the
change in lifetime and that's a
concentration
independent measure of the
energy transfer so how tightly the
proteins are bound to each other
and and so it's the distance between the
peaks that we measure
in order to determine how tight the
binding is
and if you collect lots of this data and
that's what's shown here now
this is real data but repositioned
so each of these cells is colored by the
extent to which
there is a flim-fret interaction within
them
with red being quite low or
none up to blue where you've got about a
15 percent
flim fret efficiency and so you can see
that you get all of the information
that you need for a binding curve
particularly when you use
a transient transfection for the
acceptor
because then the acceptor is present at
different concentrations
in different cells and so you can get
everything you need to generate a
binding curve
this is a nice illustration of how you
end up with the binding curve but what
does the data really look like
shown here and this is the same
experiment
this is now m73 to venus so a different
donor acceptor pair
uh when we first started doing these
experiments m certain three didn't exist
it's a much better pair because you have
a
longer lifetime for absolutely three so
the dynamic range is greater
so the rest of my talk i'll be using
cerulean to venus
where cerulean is the donor
and you can see there the regions of
interest that are outlined in yellow
automatically by the computer and uh
in the venous channel you can see that
not all cells are expressing venus and
those that are are expressing venus at
different levels
and i've provided blow ups below each of
those the
of the little area in the box and over
then on the right you see the raw data
and to get a good curve which is shown
here that's
about 5 000 measurements so that big
pile of data looks noisier than it
really is
because there's so much of it
but if you look at the little red points
along that graph those are actually the
averages within those windows that are
set by the
dotted lines and the fit to a hill
equation for
generating binding constants of all of
that data
is given by that blue line and the width
of the blue line
is the 95 percent confidence interval
for the best fit of the data
so you actually get quite a nice binding
curve out of this
even though on the y-axis here using the
ratio of venus to serving 3 which is
sub-optimal we really want to know the
bound fraction
and the concentration so on the
y-axis we have the flim-fret efficiency
and on the x-axis
the ratio of venus to cerulean 3
and that gives us a pretty good
simulation for a binding curve
the hill coefficients are not right
because we don't have
actual concentrations and i'll show you
how we get actual concentrations later
but this is the quickest way to generate
a useful binding curve
and i say the quickest on a standard
microscope
5 000 measurements 10 seconds each
that's 14 hours for
every curve so this is
not screening and it's not a great way
to measure drug efficiency
because to measure drug efficacy what we
want to do
is have a drug that mimics this binding
site
that's what's shown in c there h2 and h4
positions that yellow
thing that you can see there is a drug
called abt263 or nevidiclox
and it mimics the binding site for on
bcl2 and bclxl
for the bh3 proteins and so that's going
to displace this interaction and change
that curve
and when we do that you see here abt263
displaces bad
and bid but not bim from bclxl
and this was the first actually real
surprise
so if we go through this data from left
to right we'll start with bad
and in the green
line you have the control which is the
venous bad being expressed and the cells
are treated with dmso
instead of drug to see that the dmso
isn't changing anything there's the
black line which is just the venous
fusion protein and you can see that
those two curves overlap
we have a control where we make a
genetic mutation
in the bh3 protein that
reduces binding it's those two residues
that the drug is meant to
copy so it's bh32a because the
two residues have been changed to
alanine and you can see for bad
that that really reduces binding and you
get a
curve that's completely different that's
actually mostly collisions because
it's there's a lag phase but then it's
just a straight line
and the probability of colliding goes up
with concentration so you can tell the
difference between
real binding and collisions by the shape
of the curve
the blue one is the effect of abt263
and so you see what you see there is
that the drug
is kicking bad off of bcl
excel not completely because it doesn't
it doesn't go
on top of the red line but sufficiently
that you can see that the blue line is
truncated pretty early
and that's because you now have enough
bad kicked off bcl excel that the cell
is dying
and you get exactly the same results
with
vtbid in the next panel
where now the blue line actually isn't
even closer to the red line
so we can conclude from this that abt263
displaces t bid from bclxl
better than it displaces bad but you'll
see in the last panel
with vimb venus bim el
that there's no displacement there's no
displacement by the mutation
or by the drug i said this was
surprising why is it surprising
well because if you use purified
pieces of the proteins without the
membrane binding domains
then this is not the result that you get
in spr or other biophysical assays using
the purified proteins and peptides and
pieces of proteins all of these
experiments
bim is displaced equivalently to
bad and bid from bcl excel
but in a living cell that doesn't happen
to cut a long story short a story i'm
not going to sell
i'm not going to talk about today
we were eventually able to identify that
there's a second binding site in beniel
that people were cutting off because
it's within the membrane binding region
of bim
and it's that second binding site that's
making
the complex resistant to the drug
so here's a result that was completely
unobtainable
using conventional approaches used in
pharma and drug discovery
but by measuring the interactions in a
living cell
you find out the drugs don't work
exactly the way you thought they did
so there's there's value here but
remember that each of these curves took
14 hours to generate it's not exactly
screening
right so how are we going to get to
screening
well the way we did that was to build a
new machine
and that's a machine that will measure
fluorescence lifetimes and intensities
rapidly and
this is the instrument that we built
here i'm going to take you through
how it works and what it is that we
needed to do
to make screening possible and i will
tell you as well that
similar machines not not this one but
similar machines are now commercially
available
so it is possible to for any of you
to do this in a screening type mode
you'll need to make some software
changes that the companies have not
anticipated
but the hardware is now available so i
assume that the software will
come along as well okay so what do we
what do we have to do how does it work
how do we get it faster
well we made two changes we put in a
hyperspectral detector
that allows us to detect all the
different wavelengths
as we need to be able to measure the
concentrations
of the donor and acceptor and then we
still need a measure of their
interaction which is concentration
independent
so we're still using time correlated
single photon
counting but if you look in the bottom
left hand corner you'll see that the
detection system
has many more detectors so we've built
in
eight parallel detectors using
d-shaped mirrors to carve off some of
the
photon beam to each of the detectors now
to give you a little perspective on this
and
just how fast these measurements are
each one of these avalanche photodiodes
is about the size of a fat cell phone
a little bit thicker than the normal
cell phone and
a relatively small smartphone
and they're spaced only a few
millimeters apart
and we have to account for the length of
time it takes
light to move from one detector to the
next
to be able to make these measurements
correctly
so we need to know how long it takes
light
to go about three inches and account for
that when you
be correct for the time
fortunately in in any commercial
instrument they do that for you
but just just to give you an idea what's
going on
and then in addition to that we have our
hyperspectral detector and you'll see
why we need that on the next slide but
essentially what we need to be able to
do
is to use the intensity of the
two fluorophores to get concentration
and the way we do that is to do standard
curves
the same way you would in any
biochemistry experiment
the trick here not invented by me but by
paul french
in england is that at time zero
the time correlated single photon
counting
at time zero the probability of an
energy transfer event is
also almost zero so you can
use the time zero photons so
set your counter to count the time zero
photons
and those are proportional to
concentration and you can see that here
where we do
a concentration response curve where you
have the concentration of m
cerulean 3 on the y-axis and that counts
on the x-axis
and you get a nice straight line using
the hyperspectral detector we can
account for any bleed through
from the cerulean into the venous
channel
and be able to measure the venous
intensity
this is not affected so much by the
energy transfer
because of the hyperspectral separation
and so again we can get a nice straight
line
for the venous concentration which is
independent of
the energy transfer so now we have
everything we need we have our two
protein concentrations and we have the
fret data which will give us the bound
fraction
so now we can actually get a kd and
measure that
in the live cell so what did we need to
do next
one more innovation we need to have
intelligent selection of rois
so what i'm showing you here is an image
and then the
regions of interest for that image are
illustrated in that sort of rust color
next to that next to the intensity image
and the normal way that you do rois and
you cannot collect enough photons
so that you have a good signal to noise
ratio is to just bin
and all of you are familiar with binning
on your microscope
so in here we've got a three by three
bin uh
it's used as a kernel which means it
moves one pixel across the image and
averages the nine pixels in that square
at each point and this is absolutely
conventional way
of bending the data so that you get good
counting statistics
the problem with it as you can see there
is that most of those x's are not on the
gray object in the image
and so you're not measuring
the a single environment you're not
measuring where the binding
interaction is taking place you're
measuring
leftover protein that's in the cytoplasm
that's not involved in binding
and so your answer is quite complicated
this is very inefficient it's also slow
to calculate
so we've replaced that now with a
intelligent way of binning where we
seed on bright spots and then use a
watershed algorithm
out to accumulate enough pixels to get
good counting statistics
it means that each region of interest is
small it then defines your resolution
limit
a downside to this is that they're not
all the same size
areas of the cell where the
signal is low will be at lower
resolution and areas where the signal is
high
but that's a compromise that's pretty
easy to live with
because the resolution is still much
better than you get
with a square inning so
once we've done that then we can take
all those little rois and we can plot
them on a graph
and here you see one of those graphs
for some reason part of it is missing
that's too bad
but you can believe me over at the axis
that the points go down to zero
and again most of those points then fit
on a nice binding curve
we still have points down near the
bottom that are stray
points that look like they've fallen
from the cloud up above
those are still small areas of cytoplasm
that we're measuring
where there is no binding partner um
and so this way of selecting rois has
improved the data a lot but it's not
a complete solution we're working on a
complete solution now
anyway you get nice binding curves so
here's the data
the average data and now we're using
only a single well uh much fewer images
and the blue is the binding of bad to
bclxl
you see a very nice binding curve
the mutation i showed you before where
you make a mutation in bad we've made a
more dramatic mutation to get rid of the
residual binding that was still there
and so the gray line at the bottom is
nice and straight
and that's collisions in the
mitochondrial membrane
and then you have the red one which is
now the effect
of a bcl-xl inhibitor a1331852
it's a nice mouthful but now
you can see that that bcl excel
inhibitor is quite effective because it
essentially reduces the curve to almost
completely to
collisions there's still a little bit of
a binding curve there
but most of the
bad has been displaced off bclxl by this
this drug so now we can get
curves that now notice the axes are
different
on the bottom we have free venous and
micromolar
and on the y-axis
we have bound fraction so that means we
we're actually
able now to measure a real kd in cells
okay so we've gotten here what are we
going to do with this
what are we going to use it for and to
explain in
this particular case what we did with it
and it's a good example because it tells
you
the kind of use that you can make of
this in any system so
any protein protein interaction system
that you might be working with
you can now use in in the way that i'm
going to describe for the bcl2 family
proteins
but it does mean that i'm going to have
to introduce you to
more bh3 proteins not just bad
and more anti-appetite proteins not
bclxl
but it's really the bh3 proteins that
there's a lot of
so we need to talk about the good the
bad and the ugly
in terms of bh3 proteins and bh3
mimetics
i have to tell you a little bit about
how the system works
so how does it work here's a diagram
of the outer mitochondrial membrane
on this i have the anti-appetite
proteins in that sort of purple color
and they're bclxl bcl2 mcl1 and bclw
there are the poor formers right beside
them that are in the sort of greenish
color
back and back we're not going to worry
about those today at all
what we want to worry about are the bh3
proteins and they come in two colors
the cyan color bad and noxa and
the red color bid and bim
the important thing about that
distinction is that the
activator ones combine to backs and back
as well as binding to bcl2 and bclxl
whereas the cyan ones the sensitizer
bh3s bind only to the anti-apothic
proteins
why am i telling you all this because
when you now start to measure
kds in live cells
the advantage and disadvantage of the
approach all at once
is that you're measuring all of these
interactions
the effect of all of these different
interactions on the specific interaction
that you're interested in
so the fact that the activators will
bind to your protein
of interest say it's the venous pcl
excel
or cyrillin bclxl it'll also bind to
backs and that's a competing side
reaction
that ends up being accommodated into
your
binding curve so while the kds are not
biochemically pure they're much more
reflective of what's
actually happening in the cell so i
think this is actually a real advantage
to
the approach the other thing we have to
talk about is the bh3 memetics
and they work by binding to the
anti-apotic proteins
most people think of it as they just
bind and inhibit but that's not correct
these are competitive inhibitors so you
have yet another binding constant here
and so you're trying to swamp out
the binding of a sensitizer and
activator
to the anti-amphitic protein using a
drug that's a bh3 memetic
and what we want to do is to measure
the effectiveness of bh3 and medics as
these march
through to the clinic because they're on
their way venetoclax has already turned
the corner in and has been a spectacular
success for chronic lymphocytic leukemia
so we want to be able to measure the
different bh3 memetic drugs in
live cells and then
be able to compare them to each other
one nice thing
and the other thing is to actually be
able to ask
are they doing exactly what they're
designed to do
we already saw with abt263
that it does not displace bim from bclxl
even though it was originally designed
to do so
okay so let's look at some data
so here's measuring the dissociation
constants now
and we're back to that same graph that i
showed you before
we have the nice nice binding curve for
bcl excel and bad
you have your equilibrium down below of
donor to acceptor
and you're measuring that kd and the bh3
proteins that we're looking at here are
bad
bim bid puma big and noxa
in each case there's a bh34e mutation
that's four glutamic acids that prevents
binding or reduces binding
and so now we can actually talk about
real kds
a new wrinkle so the kds that you see
there
bad bim bid puma bic they're all
three or four micro bowler
and we know that they're not we know
that they're actually less than that
so what's going on well when you over
express proteins in the cell
the other caveat to this whole approach
is that you need to over express
proteins themselves
the local concentration at the
mitochondria
can be very high because you're doing
over expression if the concentration is
above the kd
then the kd that you measure is half the
concentration that's expressed at that
location
so that's why we're getting micro molar
kds
for those noxa uh nox's
k where uh the expression is actually
below the kd
and so that's a real kd for noxa eight
micromolar
so it binds to bcl excel but it binds
very poorly
and then the red you can see that the
mutation has shifted the kd to something
that's just impossible to achieve in
cells so
you would not get binding cells except
maybe for tbidid
okay so now we can get kds
uh we can measure the effect on that
apparent kd even though it's not the
real biochemical kd
we can measure the effect of that kd of
a mutation or a drug
which is our our goal so now we can do
an experiment an actual screening
experiment
so here's the screen bcl xl bcl2 mcl1
and bclw
the four major anti-apatic proteins
cells
they're bh3 binding partners bad beam
bid
puma and noxa so we're going to measure
the binding
of all of the bh3 proteins to each of
the anti-apoptotic proteins
and then we're going to displace that
with one of the drugs that's listed
in the table and the target for each of
those drugs the published target for
each of those drugs is listed beside it
we need 1 800 measurements per
combination to get nice binding curves
there's 360 combinations so we need to
make
650 000 measurements per experiment
and of course we want to do this three
times so
now you see why you need a screening
instrument even to do
a secondary screen on
compounds that you're already pretty
sure of you've got to generate and
collect a lot of data
what's it look like here we are we
finally got there
we have a bunch of inhibitors that we're
testing here
they're listed down the left-hand side
across the top we have the different bh3
proteins
this one as is labeled as bcl2 as the
target so we're looking at displacement
of
bad beam bid puma bicondoxa
from bcl2 by each of the
drugs that's listed down the left
displacement is red so red is dead
and blue is lack of displacement so
the table actually becomes although
complicated
uh very easy to read quite quickly and
you remember from before our positive
control
abt 263 which is the second from the top
you can see that at 10 micromolar
you're getting off of the compound
you're getting a kd of 10 micromolar for
the interaction
so you're getting displacement because
the concentration in the cell is only
around three micromolar
so that that's a compound that is
actually displacing so you don't have to
be red
even yellow is is already working
so and and that has i've shown you the
data for that already
so that's abt263 and bad we already
looked at 263
and bim and again you see there's no
displacement those are all
blue for t bid you do see displacement
for puma a new surprise no displacement
of puma
even though that everyone you know the
marketing
people would tell you that it does no
displacement of pick
and very efficient displacement of noxa
but that's because knoxville barely
binds to be
sealed anyway the other drugs there
at101 2-methoxyantomycin
bm1074 they don't do anything
they don't displace any of these barely
even displace a little bit of noxia
so they're really non-functional in
living cells
azd4320 an astrazeneca compound
works very well for bad works for bim
not great there's an error in the data
there as you might expect when you're
doing
screening uh just the one error between
11 and 12.
for tbid it works well look again
puma nothing no displacement of puma
bake is displaced noxus displaced
with abt-199 which is the absolutely
killer
uh bcl2 inhibitor you can see that most
of the cells are red so you're getting
displacement
there's variations in color there i
don't have time to talk about that today
but the problem or the wrinkle or the
complication however you want to think
about it
is that abt-199 is itself fluorescent
and
undergoes energy transfer with cerulean
so you're exchanging
one fret for a different thread
and the calculations become very
complicated
so we're still working on sorting that
in the next one
is a yes uh cirlono i think it is
a company you can't remember anyway
another company
uh bcl2 bcl excel inhibitor and
it works for bad doesn't work for bim
works for bid
doesn't work for puma uh works a bit for
bic
and of course knocks on okay
now you know maybe this is just my
imagination
but when we go forward and we test bclxl
we see that there are dramatic
differences so it's not just my
imagination
you can see that our positive control
abt263 still works for bad
bid you can see that the
astrazeneca compound which is
supposed to be specific for bcl2
is also hitting bcl-xl not as much but
it is
this place is bad uh uniquely it
displaces bim
which we have not seen we had not seen
before this place is bid
doesn't touch puma it does displace pick
uh a 33185
i introduced you to earlier this is was
originally discovered
by wehi it's now an abbott
compound and it's absolutely astounding
even at
low micromolar uh low
actually low nanomolar it displaces bad
bid all of them even puma the only drug
that displaces puma from anything
and bic and uh then the
s55746 there's also some displacement
but
in this case it's bid that's not
displaced
so that's a surprise because normally it
is relatively easily displaced
and knocks out part of the reason
showing you this is that we have a
problem with boxing
and the problem there is that there's
built into the software automatically
if the data doesn't generate a good
curve
it won't give you a kd it instead gives
you these symbols that says that
the binding is too low or there's too
much noise and whatever it can't
fit a binding curve which means that we
can resort to
the original way we that we used to do
this just just calculating resistance
uh which is essentially you know what's
the bound fraction
uh in the absence of drug and then
you're subtracting the bound fraction in
the presence of drug
and looking for that difference and when
you do that the results that you get for
noxa
are exactly what you would expect the
bcl-xl inhibitors displaced noxa
and the mcl1 inhibitors don't so
the result is biologically what you'd
expect so there's a way around it when
the data is very noisy but you
always hope for better data hey
now bclw the reason i want to show you
bclw
is a a little bit of a surprise first of
all nobody knows how any of these
compounds work
there's no published data for it so
we're seeing here
that abt263 works for bad and not
much else the astrazeneca compound
uh works for bad uh and maybe
not really for bim but a bit and it
works for bid
and this super amazing bcl excel
inhibitor a1331852
also displaces bad bit and
from bclw
and here's the surprise part because i
gave this talk
a few weeks ago not knowing
this particular answer and somebody was
involved in the discovery of this drug
put up their hand in the chat box and
told us all
that the drug was originally
screened for for displacing
bad from bclw and they then tried to
remove that activity
uh to make it bclxl specific
but the original screen was against bclw
and that probably explains why there's
still some residual activity for pclw
even though there's no activity in pcl2
so that was pretty gratifying that
we had found something unexpected but
also
sensible okay so there's a lot
i know to take in and so what i want to
do is just summarize what we learned
from all this because
what can you learn why do you do
so what did we learn first of all we
learned that a lot of the
inhibitors of ph3 medics that are for
sale
are not so you know despite their
claimed potency specificities
they don't work live cells and so
they're illustrated here in yellow
the other is that there's a bunch of
others that
whose specificity is not what
is claimed in the literature also so
that's leaving us
actually not very many that actually do
exactly what you think they do so that's
that's an easy take-home message but we
actually learned a lot more than that
if we come back here one of the things
we learned was that noxa binds to bcl2
bclxl and bclw but with low affinity
published literature says it just binds
to mcl1
is that something new i've just shown
you none of the bh3 memetics work
exactly as specified
maybe a couple of the ncl1 ones but none
of the ones were
proteins we looked at today none of the
bh3 mimetics inhibits
come up bcl2 bcl
w they astrazeneca one
puma to excel a bit but i'm not
astrazeneca the avid one
but in general it doesn't work
and that's totally new uh only
astrazeneca's
az4320 inhibits bim binding to
bcl2 bcl excel and bclw which is
really different from the other drugs
this one here
abv's drug that we just talked about
it's definitely the world's best
inhibitor of bcl excel
but it also inhibits bcl w by divided
bid
astrazenecas
and if acd4320 bcl2 and bclxl
as advertised but also bclw
and since toronto was surveyed surveys
bcl2 inhibitor
s55746 and it was bco2 mining
that or puma
uh and it's supposed to be specific for
bcl-2 but it's not it inhibits pcl excel
by
that so we actually learned an awful lot
a lot of that may not be all that
relevant to you but the reason i went
through it all
is to say that with this uh ability to
be able to measure
binding constants in live cells we were
able to generate a huge amount of new
information
about all of these drugs which are
marching through clinical trials and
towards patients
that you couldn't learn any other way
and so for
all of you who may now or in the future
be looking at a protein protein
interaction in a live cell
i think that uh flim fret is is that has
the opportunity
to provide you with a lot of information
that you really can't get any other way
so and last but not least loss of bh3
memetics do not inhibit
anything so uh be careful when you spend
your money
because lots of them don't work all
that's left now is for me to thank
people who worked on this in my lab most
of the work that you saw on the big
screen was elizabeth osterlund a phd
student in the lab
chin fang is a joint student with chin
fang is my collaborator
on the engineering part and he had
hermes as a joint student
with uh chin fang and there's
lots of people in the lab that have put
some time into this
but particularly shanlou adrian
newtorette
and james pemberton and thank you all
for listening
thank you very much i'm ready to take
questions
and thank you dr andrews for that
outstanding presentation
we do not have time for a q a this
afternoon we
want to encourage our audience members
to please
submit their questions and questions we
didn't have time today
we will address them via email dr
andrews however i want to offer you
some time for closing remarks would you
like to say anything to the audience
before we close
i don't i don't even know am i even on
you are okay well uh thank you for
uh listening and participating i'm sorry
that some of the slides don't present
properly
we'll get that fixed when we post it for
on demand watching
and and thank you all for coming i
really appreciate it
and thank you again dr andrews and thank
you to the audience
for your participation this presentation
will be available for on-demand viewing
in the sbi 2 virtual conference for 12
months
and please remember to share it with
your colleagues who may have been
interested in today's topic and don't
miss out on the other presentations
on our agenda thank you again for your
participation until next time
stay safe stay healthy take care bye